muchas gracias por esta comunicación
abogada los demócratas se enfocan en las
amenazas que un tribunal conservador de
6-3 podría plantear a la ley de cuidado
de salud asequible y a los derechos al
aborto que tan tensas se esperan las
audiencias
bueno yo creo que una de las cosas más
importantes como lo acaba de señalar es
el hecho de que se están dando en un
contexto que no tiene precedentes cuando
todos en este momento toda la población
está votando muchas de las bolas con
votando por adelantado o sea que el
mandato que se supone que se haría un
presidente puede
y nombrar a una y nominar a una juez o
un juez del tribunal supremo y refleja
que tiene el apoyo de el pueblo en este
momento eso está incierto pero yo me
imagino que los demócratas tratarán de
evitar hablar sobre los vicios de
religión en donde se ha atacado mucho
que ella es una católica ferviente pero
también muy conservadora dentro del
catolicismo y yo me imagino que eso es
parte de lo que van a tratar de evitar y
más concentrarse en la filosofía
judicial de ella que es una filosofía
conservadora ella fue ayudante del
pasado huesca lee a el difunto huesca
lee a que tiene una visión de que la
constitución tiene que interpretarse de
una forma original y que no se tiene que
adaptar que no es una constitución viva
que se adapta a los cambios sociales a
los cambios culturales de una nación y
también es recordar y yo me imagino que
se lo van a recordar que la constitución
de un andamiaje de protección a los
derechos de los individuos y las
minorías cuando la mayoría a través de
las leyes legislar y violan y vulneran
derechos de los individuos y de las
minorías pues para el tachi está el
tribunal así que no parece que se van a
concentrar más en la filosofía judicial
porque políticamente no creo que es una
buena idea contentar a que la realidad
soy abogada y tienen los demócratas
alguna posibilidad de detener la
confirmación si no pueden hacerlo qué
opinión le merece la posibilidad de
agregar nuevos escaños a la corte
suprema y es que esto ya parece una
posibilidad si los demócratas toman el
control
o sea esto es una posibilidad que se
está planteando nadie la acepta todavía
porque dicen que es muy prematuro y
además yo creo que pudiera también
afectar en el electorado las elecciones
y poder sobre el candidato vaivén y la
propia candidata de presión presidencial
canal a salir no han querido abundar
sobre esto pero esto es una estrategia
que pudiera realmente tener a su
disposición del partido demócrata si
gana y obtiene la mayoría en el senado
porque esta sería la primera vez con el
nombramiento de esta vuelta que se
consolida de una manera significativa
una visión conservadora de la
constitución una visión conservadora de
cuál es el rol del tribunal supremo que
y un ir atrás en muchos de los derechos
que se han logrado a reconocer con ese
mismo tribunal